la última prueba de misiles de Corea del
Norte aterrizó A solo 200 km de Japón
analizamos la trayectoria del vuelo del
misil balístico intercontinental que fue
lanzado
otoño tenía una capacidad de vuelo de
más de 15.000 kilómetros lo que
significa que tenía suficiente alcance
para llegar al territorio continental de
Estados Unidos
el misil aterrizó en el mar tras haber
recorrido mil kilómetros alcanzando una
altitud de 6.100 kilómetros y una
velocidad máxima de más de 16.000 millas
por hora en un año en el que se ha
abatido récord de pruebas de misiles en
Corea del Norte El Primer Ministro
japonés reaccionó durante una reunión de
líderes de Asia Pacífico en Tailandia
Esta es una alta frecuencia de
lanzamiento repetido sin precedentes y
este lanzamiento actual no podemos
permitirlo en lo absoluto
esto en una reunión de emergencia con
Estados Unidos y sus aliados convocada
en mitad de la Cumbre para denunciar la
muestra de agresión
condenamos enérgicamente estas acciones
y volvemos a pedir a Corea del Norte que
deje de cometer actos ilegales y
desestabilizadores en respuesta a Corea
del Sur envío una formación de aviones
de combate a lo largo de la costa
oriental de la Península coreana en una
muestra de fuerza y realizó ejercicios
de tiro sobre objetivos que simulaban
lanzadores de misiles móviles coreanos